hi i'm jessica and i'm from the
university of zurich and i'll be
introducing silva which is a learning
management system we developed
hi so I'm Jessica and I'm from the
University of Zurich this is my
colleague Mike also from the University
and together we developed Silva which is
a platform that we developed and Mike
will join back at the end if you have
any Q&A so the first thing I want to
talk about is at the University we have
a grading problem and it's not just at
the university I think it's a problem
for all educators that when you consider
for example grading a typical final exam
this could take one minute per question
to grade so quite quite simple quite
easy but then when you consider one
final exam it's 20 questions 20 minutes
grading one exam per student now when
you also consider at the University of
Zurich our introductory mathematics
course this is 500 students and this is
virtually impossible to use just manual
grading because right this is already
ten thousand minutes
that's three full working weeks of just
grading and that's a lot of time
that's very labor intensive we're a
little lazy so it's it's something that
we thought was a problem and we're Silva
comes in so Silva is this fully
integrated platform where professors can
create their materials distribute it and
benefit from the automated grading so
I'm just going to switch over now to
Silva here on a web browser and I'm just
going to go through a demo assessment so
you can see what the student experience
is like so here is kind of the
introductory page for this five question
assessment and here the first question
is a randomized multiple-choice question
very straightforward a lot of platforms
can do this right solve X plus 1 equals
5 for X so here I'll answer the solution
which is 4 and when I click Submit
I can go to question to write code with
less than 15 characters that evaluates
the following so here now you're
eliciting a code response from the
students and here I'll just use range
for this because
imple and click Submit and for the third
question so here now you can see we're
now including some visualization so
which plot shows exactly six extrema
maybe for this question I don't know the
answer so I'll answer this one
incorrectly so you can see the grade
results at the end and here so the
fourth one is named a city within 500
miles to London but outside the UK and
you can already see in this answer box
the Mathematica symbol so we're now
using the knowledge base built in
Mathematica and here maybe I write
Brussels and for the last question this
is an interactive response so here you
can see the sine plot and now we're
listening the student to interact with
giving the answer so the question is
where is the local minimum of the
function move the locator to give your
answer so here's the locator and now I'm
controlling where it is and I know the
minimum is around here so I can answer
that click Submit and the minute I click
the final submission for the entire
assessment it's all being automatically
graded in the cloud and now you can see
that was pretty quick now this is my
results page so as a student this is
what I would see for a self test so if I
scroll down here I can see some text but
what's kind of more maybe interesting
for students is to see this part so the
five questions I see I got four correct
one incorrect but the nice thing is for
example if I click on one of the
questions I can see the original
question what my answer was and a brief
explanation of why that is the correct
solution if I click on number three
which is the one I answered incorrectly
I see my answer which was this top one I
can additionally see what was the
correct answer and then also a brief
explanation so as a student I can really
understand
why I got it wrong what is the correct
solution and I don't need to go and ask
the professor afterwards so now I'm
going to go back to show you now what it
looks like from the instructor side to
create the exact assessment so Silva is
an add-on to Mathematica so here just go
to palettes I can click creo that's just
the name we use for the authoring tool
and it opens this of course I can create
new documents here but I already have
created this assessment so I'm just
going to open it and this is the
interface that an instructor would see
when they're creating the assessments
very simple straightforward interface
you have two tabs one introduction into
questions so for the introduction this
is optional you can include any any text
that you want the students to be aware
of any rules etc now for the questions
part here are the five questions so this
first one was solve X plus 1 equals 5
for X standard multiple choice I can add
as many choices as I like here and I can
determine which ones are correct by just
clicking on these toggles then when I
scroll down under reporting it's
optional if you would like to show the
student the correct solution as well as
it's optional to provide extra
explanations for the correct solution
and if you see in the title we call it
randomized multiple choice so I'll just
show you quickly after you make any
question you can always preview it so
you can see what it looks like from the
student side and here now all of the
answers are randomized right I just
added that new one that's called
alternative here but it's now in the
third slot so for example if you're in a
large classroom setting this kind of
helps with cheating as well and now for
the second question so this is the one
where we're eliciting a code response
from the students so if you look at the
original question right code with less
than 15 characters that evaluates the
following list there
kind of three different conditions right
the answer must be 15 characters or less
the answer must be a list and it must be
that exact list so it's exactly how you
write out the question as an instructor
the first line of code here you see the
students give an answer must simply be
less than 15 characters the second one
it must be a list and the third the
answer must results in evaluate to this
range and each of the getting each of
those components correct will award the
student one point so just to show you
this kind of point system if I preview
the question so right the question is
asking whatever code is input it
evaluates to this output but maybe I
don't know and I know at least this is
pretty much correct as a student so if I
submit this you'll see that actually I
don't get all of the points it's only
two out of three points and that's
because it didn't meet the condition of
being 15 characters or less but also as
you can imagine with code there are so
many different possible solutions right
earlier I showed you the answer using
range but maybe I want to use a
different solution using table so and I
submit this one this answer is also
considered fully correct because it
meets all three conditions and here for
the third example so this was where you
saw the sine plots and you'll notice now
in the question name there's actually no
number here and it's just a text
variable that says number because now
we're including parameters so parameters
allows us to define a variable between a
certain range and here the range is
between 3 to 7 so it will randomly
choose a number to put into the question
which will then also change the possible
choices that the students see and this
again will help with randomization and
also help students kind of reinforce
concepts if they're taking this exam
multiple times by themselves at home
and so here if I preview this one you'll
see so the question is which plot shows
exactly six extrema and if you keep this
image in your mind I'm just going to
refresh it and open a new preview and
every time I click preview it's opening
a new cloud object here now it says four
extrema and all of the solutions are
showing different possible answers so
this is really great for reinforcing
concepts but also to avoid cheating if
you happen to be testing in a large
classroom and for the fourth question
this was the one where we're using the
knowledge base in now in Mathematica
specifically so you can imagine this
question naima city within distance to
London but outside the UK that's
thousands and thousands of cities but
instead of having to list all of those
possible cities we just use the
knowledge base in Mathematica using geo
distance so the first condition is that
the city must be a certain distance away
from London and the second condition is
it cannot be in the UK so really simple
really straightforward and for the last
question so this is the one with the
locator and as my mean like as
interactive is this question is it's
really simple to create such a question
so here under controller body you simply
make a sine plot you add a locator you
make it dynamic and wherever the student
places this locator because on this
coordinate that becomes the point and
from this point you're asking does this
point fall within the region of the
minimum but of course with such
interactive type questions you can
always maybe be a little off of the
exact answer which is why you can also
build in kind of a tolerance level so
just to show you what this means so this
was the exact plot you saw earlier but
we're giving this tolerance level to the
students so that as long as the locator
falls within this region they're correct
because the the point of these questions
is
not to frustrate the students it's
really just reinforced that they
understand what the questions are asking
so that's all of the five questions but
at the beginning I mentioned that the
tool main benefit or one of the main
benefits is this automated grading so in
addition to being able to set up
questions in a way that you don't have
to grade at the end you have a final
summary report as well which is
automatically generated so I'm just
going to go back here so this is a list
of some courses that my colleague Mike
has been involved with where Silva was
used and just a couple of months ago the
programming bootcamp finished and this
specific class had 88 students
registered and you can see if I click
through now you can see all of the
lecture materials which I can show you
at the end if you're interested here are
all the assignments that were given to
students and then here are the final
results for those those exams so if I
click on final grade I can now see a
summary for the entire course
so in Switzerland are our grade scale is
out of six points so you can see the the
four point two one is on a six scale 72%
passed twenty five failed and the really
nice thing is you can see for example
this distribution of all the grades as
well as where all the students fall in
relation to each other
so for example if I interested in the
performance of this student I can click
on his name I can see how he performed
on all of the assignments as well as
even open a new tab where I can see more
details about his assignments and see
where he falls in relation to the other
students and this is also available to
the students so they can see a full
summary of their own grades as well as
kind of where they fall in in the course
and I think that's all we had planned to
show you but of course if you have any
Asians or anything we'd be happy to
answer them go ahead yep sorry can you
repeat the question
yep yep yes and so off kind of offer
this question so one thing is of course
even though this all automatized it's
still possible to make mistakes on the
instructor side right the way you you
phrase the question or write it out so
there's two parts one there's a feedback
section this is going to be released
soon we're on each specific question the
student can say this I want to kind of
refute this or I want to provide
feedback on this question I don't think
it's right or I think my my solution is
correct can you look at it that's one
thing and the second thing is once all
of the grades are finalized or finished
then the instructor can still go in and
review everything so if the instructor
sees okay question for everyone got
wrong is it really because they missed
something or did I miss something
so you always have the final say yep
yeah so I will try to to show this here
we go again
sorry tap
so I mean it happens all the time so you
you make a mistake you set up the
grading function incorrectly or you miss
a case and students find it and then of
course you don't want to kind of punish
them for your mistake
so watch what you can do is like listen
to the students and hear some of these
requests so they say like yeah and
question one so that happened and and
then what we can do is we can reject or
accept the request and based on a
request we can change the points or
grades for all the students or just for
one student and this is very convenient
I'll show you this example so when you
when you create an assessment then
usually it looks like this so what you
would do is you look at the question and
when nobody got four points in such a
large class chances are that you made a
mistake and so it's very easy now to
adjust the points here and you can
immediately regreat the the whole class
and you can do this afterwards and it's
tracked so that the students always know
what happened or what to change as well
and so that's it's very transparent so
what what we are working on for the next
version is that you can change all these
grading functions you have seen so for
that we need kind of like replicate some
of the functionalities you have seen in
the mathematical tool and cRIO so we
will move this to the cloud and so then
we can we can adjust this as well
so yeah it's quite quite flexible two
years I was a student in one of his
courses during my masters and I remember
the very first class where we use Silva
of course as a student with new tech
when you're so used to one way you're of
course open-minded about it but hesitant
right and but I will say one this using
Silva compared to what we another LMS we
use at the university called a lot the
simplicity of this one with the
interface I mean you have three buttons
where your assignments are your grades
compared to all that where it's so many
classes so many tabs everywhere it's
just a lot of distraction that was the
first thing and second thing is to be
honest there's just a lot of
transparency on this because I can see
every single grade I receive and I can
click into the grade and then I see
every single solution and of course as
we mentioned if there's ever a time when
I felt it was unfair or something I
could report it and I mean because this
is a work in progress of course now I'm
on this side we're really happy for that
feedback because it's it's very possible
it's something that we did wrong or we
should look into yeah so I'm just adding
one more thing from the teachers
perspective what has radically reduced
is the number of exam reviews so usually
what we would do is after we publish the
grades
one month later then we set a date where
students can come to our office and then
they can look into their exam like a
paper copy and then they start
bargaining so in in question three don't
you think this this could be like one
more point
no like then I would not fail this
course so this has radically reduced so
students I understand okay if it's
graded by a computer then
and so this this is very convenient also
like answering this request like in a
large course eight assignments in the in
the exam so you get like lots of emails
and then answering them in the team and
this is this is quite difficult and so
for us I've been teaching of course this
this this actually this programming
bootcamp with Roman made out so two
lectures and we were both able to to
answer the request first trying to get
our idea was compared to two other
dozens of very like special question
types we wanted to come up with
something more general so what we have
here is what you see is like this answer
type and we only have three different
incentives at the moment but actually
you can create like most of the question
types you see in other tools using those
three so the first one is selection so
Jessica showed this so where you have
this just these alternatives and you can
then go to the options and do something
like take a subset so you can put in a
question pool and then
like like every student only gets like
five no no a hundred question from your
poor you can make it multiple selections
so then you can say like two or three
are correct and you can have this like
none of the above
this default answer and things like this
so this is our approach on making or
keeping it as simple as possible but
still having the flexibility and when
you when you go to the to the free
response free response is just anything
so we use all the interpreters which are
available in foreign language and as you
can see they're like these numbers and
integers and so on strings and texts but
we can also use color or City what
you've seen and even images so we can
create an image and then you use image
identifying to iterated so this this is
a very like powerful question type so we
can you can upload an excel notebook and
then you just tell it how to all that is
as possible and with with interactive
responds so you probably know this
Wolfram demonstrations project so our
idea was you can just take a
demonstration or a manipulate you you
used in your lecture materials put it
here and say like okay so these are the
points or parameters I'm interested in
tracking and then you just go ahead and
set up the conditions to grade it and
that's it but still you can
[Music]
so far we had no legal issues yet but
what we do like our exams are usually in
in the classroom at university so the
assignments are take-home but this is
kind of like a issue for the honor code
it would be possible to to to add more
authentication methods I mean every
student can only log into his or her
account but yes so we haven't like
invested in making this more like unique
and it's actually really tough so you
can do things like voice recognition or
images or something like this but we
haven't yet and sorry you did the second
question was so what what happens when a
student gives an answer each each
question is a separate cloud object and
they're all stored in a separate
database and we take backups every 15
minutes no no yeah and we preserve all
the other all the answers and the cloud
objects are no longer accessible so no
one can change it afterwards so we are
happy to answer more questions